Rich Eisen for the Rich Eisen show the
emmy-nominated Rich Eisen show also with
the NFL Network just buzzed us to give
us his thoughts on Tony Romo Richie Rich
how are you
DEP is always listening to you on the
way to work thanks your conversation
with the Dan nets and you know you
obviously we don't know what Romo is
gonna be like until he's on the air
right I mean until we understands in a
live game that you have to get in and
out and be concise as you point out but
in terms of what his personality is off
the air and not in some sort of
combative posture maybe with the media
yeah I am seated chalk talk with him and
Steve Young the night before Super Bowl
50 in San Francisco and he was beyond
terrific not only knowing everything
inside and out about Denver's defense
and Carolina's defense but what Peyton
Manning's strengths and weaknesses in
his at that point of his career were Cam
Newton at that point of his career
obviously is being MVP at the time but
he was terrific he was concise he was
funny he was self-deprecating he was on
top of it all passionate and I turn to
Steve Young afterwards and I said to him
Wow I mean this is somebody who can do
this for a living and he looked at me
and he goes he's one of the most
knowledgeable quarterbacks that's
playing the game right now and the one
last thing that really left a lasting
impression on me was do one of two
things either he studied his head off
for the chop talk and was prepared for
this shock talk or he was just so into
it and is such a football junkie that
that he is ready to roll for something
like this I believe it but do you think
his value would be better served as a
studio analyst where you actually he
could break down things I can see him as
opposed to just listening to his voice
where you know that gets lost when
you're doing I know
doing the number one game but it's right
it's like if there's value to Tony Romo
you might see that value more people
tuning into the pregame we're gonna tune
into the game no matter who's doing it
but you don't always turn into the
pregame look I mean you know better than
anybody about what the value of an
analyst the pregame show is but they
already have a quarterback who's been to
a Super Bowl and in MVP sitting on the
set and unless you don't need a second
one on that set hmm unless boomer wanted
to go in the booth or CBS wanted to put
boomer in the booth with mance I mean
they
if Romo is free and you also know
dancing in person certainly that
Thursday night game we did with NBC
Dallas at Minnesota I mean it was
remarkable how many cowboy fans showed
up in in Minnesota in December and you
can't put you can't you can't discount
how popular Tony Romo is and if they
wanted to replace Bill if that was
something they considered was an issue
in their number one booth and Romo is
free you know obviously it's going to
take him some time to get his chops up
to be a number one game palace to be in
that live action by but I mean he was he
was confident his voice would I mean all
of it I turned the young and I'm like
this this guy is ready to go and he
fully agree I mean that's obviously just
at any social event at a Superbowl night
but I'm sure CBS must have saw something
like that in him do you have a problem
with him jumping the line no that
happens to everybody doesn't it some
point you know a deep like what what are
you gonna do I mean what they put them
on the the B team or C team I mean maybe
he's rushed do you think that we'll be
sitting here here from now talking about
that that Romo won't have an opinion he
won't have a take that he can't he can't
get the words out it's a horrible watch
I don't I would bet I would go the other
way yeah I would say that he's going to
be
really good yeah I think he'll make the
transition I think my only concern was
you know how much pressure is attached
to that first game how he reacts to that
he doesn't second-guess himself it's
it's like playing quarterback you know
you're gonna you're never gonna be ready
for the game until you get into the game
and then once he gets it right the game
will slow down for him just like it did
for him as a quarterback he'll find his
spots I'm sure Troy Aikman will give him
some advice he'll do his homework and
Nan so we'll set him up nicely so I I
don't think that that's going to be a
big deal I think the bigger deal is if
I'm hiring Tony Romo at what point do I
worry that somebody calls him and says
hey such-and-such just went down with an
injury season-ending injury we want to
know if you want apply and I think that
that'll happen this year oh that's true
and he didn't shut the door I mean he
gave a very Jordans far vien type
response to the percentage of his
retirement possibility and you know and
and and obviously if he's got a cowboy
game that's gonna be something he's
going to have to address to a fan base
that's tuning in to watch the other team
play you know and and you couldn't have
hit the nail more on the egg that many
people come out of football or whatever
sport they're playing and think it's
very easy to just talk about it yeah and
then and then they fall flat on their
face and there was one player you know
one hoops player I remember when I was
at the mothership geez you're afraid
that that he was terrific in the
meetings but was terrible on the air and
and we found out the reason why is
because he could curse his head off in
the meetings and had to remove the
not-safe-for-work language when he's on
the air and couldn't put a sentence
together so to make the transition now
there could be pitfalls I just don't
think Romo is gonna have it thanks for
the phone call rich always be P like
that sir Rich Eisen his show was
nominated for a Sports Emmy it follows
this show coming up at noon eastern nine
Pacific on DirecTV the audience number
channel 239 the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
you